[Applause]
[Music]
nuclear power
is like adult entertainment a lot of
people say that they don't
like it but then you do find it pretty
much everywhere maybe you thought that
nuclear
power wasn't fashionable anymore maybe
you thought that after fukushima the
whole world
just started showing its back to nuclear
power
well in fact the opposite is true
[Music]
in fact if you're watching this video in
america in the uk
or well any european country the chances
are that you're consuming nuclear power
at this very moment i know what you're
going to say you're going to say oh come
on simon you're exaggerating
most countries don't have nuclear power
plants right i mean
in fact there are only 30 countries with
nuclear reactors
this means that just one out of every
six or seven countries
has it but think about it many of those
countries they're really small
as you can imagine vanuatu doesn't have
the same power needs as
china
if we're talking about the biggest
economies those with membership in the
g20
only five of them have no reactors and
of those
turkey is starting to build their own
facilities and italy imports 10 of their
energy from the nuclear power plants in
france so let's face it most wealthy
countries use nuclear power and the
emerging ones
they're starting to join the club too
especially china you see there are three
indicators for determining whether a
country will adopt nuclear power
that go hand in hand economic growth
more power demands
and more pollution so imagine for a
moment
chinese factories demanding more and
more energy then add to this the heavy
migration from villages to cities and
boom all of a sudden we have thousands
of offices
thousands of factories thousands of
malls and millions of chinese people
turning on their lights at the exact
same time
[Music]
cities like beijing shanghai shenzhen
they make american cities
look like small villages in the alps so
just imagine how much
power these cities need of course this
explains
why china is becoming a green energy
disneyland
they can't stop building solar panels
wind turbines and hydroelectric plants
year after year china is leading
investments in renewable energy sources
and you would think that after fukushima
they're no longer interested in nuclear
but
you'd be absolutely wrong
[Music]
according to the international atomic
energy agency asia is where
half of all new reactors are being built
and look we're not talking about
three or four in total here more than 27
reactors are currently being built and
most of them
they're in china
[Music]
and i know what you're thinking china's
a dictatorship right so the only reason
they're building that many reactors is
because
they don't need to listen to their
people they can do whatever they want
again you'd be wrong asian citizens
they're largely in support of nuclear
power
look at taiwan as an example it's a
democratic country and here they made a
referendum about whether they should
close nuclear reactors
and the citizens they said no even in
japan the land of fukushima
we're seeing news like this
[Music]
japan court rejects lawsuit against
construction of nuclear power plant so
the question is
why what happened with nuclear power
that makes the asians and particularly
the chinese
so excited what are the main companies
involved in this and is it a good or is
it a bad idea
well today we're going to answer all of
these questions but before we do
let's take a look back at the history
the sleeping dragon you know the dragon
smork from the hobbit sleeping on top of
that mountain of gold
well in mao zedong's china mao was that
sleeping dragon but instead of sleeping
on wealth and
treasure he was sleeping on rice china
it was poor and agricultural and
this is how it remained for decades
during those times china was too poor to
buy the insanely pricey technology
needed for nuclear plants
at the beginning of the 1990s china had
no reactors
whatsoever in 1990 the power mix in this
country was 20
hydroelectric and 80 fossil fuels
mainly in coal
but then 2017 rolls around and things
changed of course china still relies on
coal but
not as much why well look coal produces
the most pollution of any energy source
and this explains why beijing is so
famous
for its smog and why people have to wear
masks there
and don't get me wrong this pollution
won't change in the near future
especially with news like this
china coal power building boom sparks
climate warning think about it the only
natural resource china has
is coal so they can't just stop using it
like that
but there is a problem coal and
hydroelectric produced enough power
during mao's time
but in just 20 years energy consumption
in china has multiplied
by 10. so essentially they need other
sources of energy
and they need them badly
and this is why in just 27 years china
has built 40
brand new reactors that's already more
than russia has
so we could say that the sleeping dragon
is now wide awake but okay okay we said
that china is investing a lot in green
energy
too so why do they still need nuclear
well let's have a look
[Music]
hungry for uranium smog the dragon he
loved gold the chinese
dragon well it loves uranium right now
china is building 11 brand new reactors
with a greater capacity than
all of the united kingdom's reactors but
hold on a minute because
this is nothing just look at the
expectations for 2013.
china is set to overtake us as biggest
nuclear energy nation iea
says according to the iea china is set
to overtake the united states as the
biggest
nuclear energy nation and i know we are
now thinking all of these predictions
are after the fukushima incident in 2011
which was caused by a tsunami
that hit a nuclear power plant in japan
it was a huge catastrophe
forcing thousands of people to move
turning the water toxic
and making death a real and present
danger
so why does china keep investing in
nuclear
even after this has happened i mean
isn't green energy
enough
[Music]
well here's the important thing the key
point when we're talking about energy
is that hardly any of it can be stored
maybe in the future
lithium batteries will improve but
currently it's very expensive to store
electricity on a large scale and this is
the main problem with green energy
[Music]
solar panels are good but what happens
at night wind turbines are great but
what do we do when there's no wind and
you've got to add to this
what we said before so far china relies
too much on coal because
they don't have to import it but all of
this it causes a lot of pollution
so well what are the alternatives well
you might think well how about gas right
now china reports 40
of the gas they use and this creates a
lot of political problems
we have a whole series of videos
covering the gas wars besides gas in
asia is very expensive
because of things like this
japan spot lng price hits three year
high in january
basically china is constantly competing
with japan to attract all those ships
with
their liquefied natural gas and this has
increased the price
a lot so the reality is there's only
really one alternative and that's
nuclear
it's efficient people can use it all day
long and as counter-intuitive as it
sounds
it's less polluting but hold on a minute
because it's really not that simple you
see
if you want to have nukes you need two
things you need some
very expensive technology and you need
uranium
and uranium isn't something you can go
and buy at the supermarket
so well how's china doing it well let me
tell you
made in china china is famous for
copying products from the west
so yes you can imagine what we're going
to say right now
where did china import its nuclear
technology from
well of course you'll learn from the
best in the beginning they started
working with the french nuclear bear
moth framatome which you might know by
their old name
arava china also made deals with
american westinghouse and the
russian rossaton well well but this this
was during the 1990s so what happened
during the 2000s
[Music]
well china went to all of these
companies and said essentially well okay
guys
from now on next to any of your
engineers there's got to be a chinese
engineer this is how china
gained all of the technological secrets
from the best nuclear companies
and i can tell what you're thinking
you're absolutely right nobody
apparently negotiates better than the
chinese
so after 10 years the third generation
of chinese manufactured nuclear reactors
are already here
[Music]
china set to fire up world's first
ap1000 nuclear reactor
yep now china can build its own reactors
without the help of foreign companies
and even if the american westinghouse
wanted to
expand their presence in the chinese
market they would have a really hard
time
because of news like this
westinghouse could be hurt by new us
curbs on nuclear exports
but still there is one thing you cannot
copy and that's
uranium nuclear power plants they need
uranium as fuel and china
does not naturally have this resource so
they've got to import it
but again remember china's really great
at making deals the world's main uranium
producer
is kazakhstan they produce 40 of all the
uranium on the planet and china already
takes
50 of that they also have some
agreements with canada and they're
trying to do the same thing with
australia
but well that's the easy part what makes
china special is their ability to make
deals in even the most challenging
places
[Music]
china buys rio tinto steak in namibia
uranium for 107 million dollars
[Applause]
[Music]
china gains ground in niger to get
uranium to increase their nuclear
production
so in summary made in china has expanded
to the whole
world but not only that china's
affordable technology is making nuclear
power available in places that
it was impossible to get it before for
example the crown jewel of this brand
new industry is the hualong 1 reactor
this will be used in countries like
argentina and pakistan
which are going to start using more and
more nuclear power too
but this isn't just about the emerging
world the state-owned chinese nuclear
company is participating in the
construction of a brand new reactor in
the united kingdom
but well that's a story for another
video as you might have already guessed
this
is just the first chapter of another
series of videos we're going to be doing
about the comeback of nuclear power if
you don't want to miss all that don't
forget to subscribe and hit the bell
button so you won't miss any of our
posts in the meantime
over to you
where do you think the chinese nuclear
ambitions will lead do you think they'll
keep building nuclear plants or will
they focus most of their efforts into
developing more green energy well
leave your answer in the comments
section below also don't forget to visit
reconsidermedia.com the podcast that
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine
if you liked this video give it a thumbs
up and as always i'll see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and hear even more of my lovely
voice
you can join us at reconsider media we
have a podcast at reconsider media.com
podcast see you there